I won't tonight its documentary because
I've been on TV quite a bit on property
shows and there's always an agenda or
you know a twist or a spin and I wanted
to show what real life come up like as a
property investor a lot of people ask me
what's your average day look like so I
guess when we're getting a delete
weekend I guess I am an entrepreneur my
main business is I buy and rent out buy
and sell buy and trade houses so I'm a
property entrepreneur I made a lot of
money from property and being creative
doing Lease Option agreements and joint
ventures and then I'd like to think I'm
also a pretty good trainer so I'm not
alone in the business my beautiful wife
Amanda is also my business partner I
have a company I run that converts
properties into multi let properties and
I work alongside Daniel in the property
business since marrying Amanda I'm
happier than I've ever been uh my
business makes more money our business
makes more money than it's ever made by
a long way and she's just my everything
and we are having our first baby real
soon
so I'm really excited she's an
incredible wife and she's gonna be a
fabulous mom so this can be a real life
shift Forest
the next crash course now is oh my gosh
two days oh I've got a lot of prep to do
so it's crazy it's just two days crash
course is a two-day property event it's
really high-energy and always a lot of
fun I love doing them because I get to
share all of the knowledge about
property that I've learned over the
years it was always assumed by my dad
that when I left I would work for him
now my dad was a magician he was an
entertainer so I left school and
literally within a couple months I
realized I didn't want to do this for
the rest of my life I decided I wanted
to get into property after I went on a
holiday a mission trip and my church
sent me on and it's absolutely fantastic
and the heart was really gripped I ended
up traveling all over the place I've
been Africa India Asia different parts
of some of the poor parts of Spain and
getting back and being so alive
and having so much passion and so much
Zealand and then realize in the back in
England it's raining you have to work
for your dad doing a job that you don't
particularly enjoy
I had the Monday morning feeling times a
trillion you know completely empty for
in that in that sake but there was light
at the end of the turn on the light was
that I knew that God had a big plan for
me and I knew that I was going to be
courageous in order to take
responsibility for my own life and start
making my own decisions so I read a book
and he talked about property and
entrepreneurship and I thought you know
what I can do this I can do this and
quit my job in faith ended up going to a
property investors networking event and
I remember I remember feeling completely
out of place you know rocking up to this
event 17 years old dressed in a suit but
I felt like a kid in a suit I've never
been to a business event like this and
people would come up to me and say so
how long have you been in business
what's your property investment strategy
oh I have no idea
I guess people think that destoying
property you need a lot of money you
don't they think you need a lot of
knowledge you don't you just need to
know the right people and because I put
myself out there and I've got my
selphie in the right circles I've got a
lot of support I trained I invested in
myself see property is the second best
thing to invest in the best is yourself
so invested in myself and and as a
result of that I ended up on my first
house 18 years old there was a lot of
people in my church that seemed almost
to condemn what I was doing and the idea
was that you know you're working on your
own strengths not God strength money is
the root of all evil and there was all
these little things that people were
saying to me that began to make me feel
a little bit not guilty but started to
question myself you know Wow everyone
seems to think that this is ungodly yeah
I'm doing it for God and for people and
so I began to really question myself and
this got worse and worse and I remember
the time when I arrived at the church
doors one Sunday morning excited and
ready to go in and burn my on my pastor
he was like my spiritual father you know
my church friends they were all I had I
didn't have a social life really outside
of the church at the time and I member
just dented the church doors one morning
and they said Samuel I think it's best
that you find somewhere else to go and
I'm just like wow you know I said are
you saying that I'm not allowed to come
to this church I said I think it's best
you go and I felt you know totally
betrayed and let down misunderstood and
I went to Bible College and is possibly
the most useful 3 years of my life I
wrote a big 10 thousand word
dissertation and I did it on biblical
economics and studied what what does the
Bible actually teach about business and
what does God think about the money and
and and I came to some really
interesting conclusions and basically
the nutshell that is that if you hold
your money with open hands
and a generous heart think God bless you
you got nothing to worry about soon as
you start holding it tightly and and
clipped onto it and thinking that you
own it you know everything on this earth
is lease old and that's when it becomes
a problem it's not about how much money
you have it's about what you do with
that and when I came to some of these
conclusions I began to stop
subconsciously sabotaging my own success
because of stupid spirituality and as a
result of that my business just exploded
because I knew that God was backing me
and I knew that regardless of what the
church said what any man said what any
person said I knew that my heart was
good my intention was good and that
actually as a result of my business is
going to help a lot of people so 19
years old I bought six more houses and
it just snowballed by age 21 I had a
million pound property portfolio and
within a few short years after that
became a you know millionaire and now
I'm wealthy and I help a lot of people
and I release a lot of Christians in
particular to go and be successful as
well and there's a real rippling effect
happening now which is just fantastic
there's a training session that I don't
like now I'm not go through the other
doors so we've got Tom way to come in to
teach some of our guys our partners
about marketing systems and looks like
he's doing a great job
everyone's getting all their accounts
set up fantastic it's a lot of my stuff
pretty much all of them have been
headhunted and you know we're really
aren't we're really a family I think
they'd probably tell you themself that
working working in the business with me
and for me is probably not like most
jobs and I see I see most of my staff as
friends you know they'll come down
they'll come down to the barn I'll go in
you know there's a buzzing positive
atmosphere but I think the reason that
it's different for them not only are
they paid well treated well you know but
also we have a mission so our mission is
to help deserving people become
financially free by property that's what
we do one of the ways we do that is
through the property investors crash
course when I first ran the property
investors crash course believe it or not
it was a one-off event so the idea was I
was going to a lot of people trying to
take me up for dinner to pick my brain
on property at training Kings Christian
Business Network a lot of people were
requesting what I'd come and talk about
property and I just thought you know
what to shut everybody up I'm gonna do a
one-off event and I'll charge you know
maybe 250 quid I think it's what I
charged and it was a one-day event and I
taught everything I know someone was
into a day about property and I thought
that'd be great we'll get everybody off
my back and everyone came it was it was
a you know a crammed a crammed room and
I talked about property and everyone
loved it and we found lots of deals on
the day and people ringing up of a
some guys they getting their laptops out
and everyone went home and I thought
fantastic that's great but then they all
told their friends and family and would
go around and everyone said when are you
gonna be your next crash course then and
by the way can you make it two days
because I was like oh my goodness so I
ran another one and word got around and
as a result of that I just kept I just
kept putting it on again and again and
now it's just kind of almost got out of
control I get messages you know on my
phone like probably 20 30 messages a day
from people saying when's your next
crash good when you get Scrat skulls
it's just crazy and when we put it on it
sells out
you need to get down yeah coming up on
pancit mr. Samuel Lee welcome to the
public investors factors
[Applause]
power is completely just failed